yes if you oh I think I'll be a few ways
out there to get some good data
occurred to me that if surfers has
sensors on ball on their surfboards on
the surfboard leashes they could we
could acquire huge amount of
environmental data around the coastline
basically and there is a sparsity of
observations around the coastline so we
really don't properly understand or know
what is really happening around our
coastline but if people have these
sensors they could make a huge
difference to data collection around the
coastline with the GPS data we can
acquire information certain performance
such as how many ways you port how far
you go on each wave how fast you go on
each way and this data is useful data
we need surfers to get on board with
this idea